[Musica]
ciao a tutti sono molto molto emozionato
e felice di essere alte dix saluta anche
chi mi stava guardando su youtube sono
atenei guardatemi verificato su twitter
allora io sono molto in ansia con questo
è questo cronometro che già partito
quindi cercherò di essere molto molto
rapido e spero di non perdermi in giro
per strada perché se non sono casini
allora caos e cosmos
io cercherò di raccontarvi come il mio
mestiere si relaziona al caos
dell'informazione e della comunicazione
nel cosmos de di internet fattispecie
visto come l'ho messa lì mi chiamo
andrea lorenzon sono un creatore di
contenuti digitali un content creator
che in inglese fa anche sempre la sua
porca figura
in pratica creo dei contenuti fatti
apposta studiati apposta fin che
funzionino attraverso i social
prevalentemente sono un videomaker
quindi io attingo da tutto ciò che mi
circonda per fare i miei video
praticamente la mia attività principale
è un canale youtube che si chiama
cartoni morti in cui pubblico dei brevi
cartoni animati uno diverso dall'altro
ma accomunati tutti dal fatto che mi
piace in farcirli di riferimenti
italiani quindi inserirò dei personaggi
famosi solo in italia
userò dei modi di dire che capiamo solo
in italia e gli ambienterò imposti
italiani ma non in grandi città proprio
nei paesi che non si incula nessuno
questo perché in italia non abbiamo una
grande tradizione dell'animazione e
quindi non siamo abituati a vedere dei
riferimenti provenire dai cartoni
animati dei riferimenti nostrani e per
questo trovato originale e simpatici non
usare e sfruttare questa enorme bagaglio
culturale che abbiamo e che spesso
secondo me viene snobbato in favore di
culture più rassicuranti come quella
americana o giapponese nell'animazione
quindi insomma per fare i miei video
attingo da tutto ciò che mi circonda a
volte vengono fuori dei video più
demenziali e idioti come le avventure
del sindaco di lignano sabbiadoro
altrimenti vengono fu altrimenti può
essere che affronti anche dei temi più
impegnativi come complottismi le pseudo
scienza e perché no anche la politica la
politica è sempre un argomento che fa
cagare sotto le persone non ho mai ben
capito per quale motivo non ho mai
voluto mettermi dei paletti
perché sì io mi sono creato questo
mestiere proprio per non avere qualcuno
che mi dicesse che cosa fare e anche
perché la mia espressione artistica e
quindi va completamente contro i mi
interessi autolimitare la mia libertà
d'espressione
sarebbe stato molto più facile per me
creare il classico prodotti non ho
nazionalpopolare che piace a tutti che
diversi tutti senza scomodare nessuno
con il tormentone e quindi regalare
quell'attimo insomma di leggerezza le
persone che specie in questo periodo
signora mia ne hanno tanto tanto bisogno
la gente vuole staccare la spina come
dice marco cappato per me sarebbe stato
molto più facile l'avrei fatto molto
volentieri se solo fosse stata una
persona più semplice con dei desideri
per terra come fare i soldi la fama e il
successo la andare in tv avere
tante persone che mi applaudono e mi
dicono che sono un grande e invece oltre
a tutte queste cose io ho bisogno anche
di esprimere me stesso e di avere delle
persone che mi apprezzino per quello che
esprimo è perciò che sono quindi avere
un pubblico che sappia scherzare su
tutto senza preconcetti
questo è il motivo che mi ha portato a
concentrarmi principalmente su temi di
natura controversa per fare una sorta di
scrematura del pubblico è un tipo di
video che ho sempre fatto fin
dall'inizio nel 2017 il quarto video che
ho pubblicato era sui vaccini quando
ancora non andavano di moda
poi ho parlato dell'omeopatia della
terra piatta sperando che non torni di
moda anche quello
insomma è un tipo di video più complesso
degli altri quindi ne facevo giusto uno
ogni tanto e poi sono come le scale
diary potere me piace cambiare però è
indubbio che le persone che mi seguono
per questo tipo di video mi diano una
carica in più
quindi ho cominciato già dall'inizio ad
affrontare temi di natura controversa
però l'inter
per no dell'ambito scientifico questo
perché nella scienza per me è più facile
trovare una fonte di informazione che io
ritengo affidabile come quella della
comunità scientifica non lo dico perché
io senta una qualche responsabilità
etica in quello che faccio vi assicuro
che non me ne frega assolutamente nulla
lo faccio perché mi piace avere una
narrazione di tipo biologico se questa
narrazione poi coincide anche con il
benessere della società ben venga ma
sappiate che non lo faccio apposta cioè
mi è venuto benvenuto così che faccio
veramente quello che mi piace a me
quindi dopo che avete capito anche che
sono un filantropo torniamo ai video di
natura scientifica
allora io cominciato a fare del video di
natura scientifica però ben presto mi
sono espanso e o invaso altri ambiti
come la politica i diritti civili
addirittura l'economia europea quindi
giustamente uno potrebbe pensare che io
sia il classico youtuber saccente che
pensa di sapere tutto di tutto e che
vuole insegnare agli altri come pensare
addirittura in modo sarcastico e ironico
vuole prendere in giro le persone che
non la pensano come lui
beh questo non è assolutamente del tutto
vero intanto il numero uno e io non
prendo mai in giro le persone singole
ma il pensiero che esse rappresentano a
volte che l'ho proprio dei dei
personaggi vaghi e metaforici per
rappresentare una corrente di pensiero
numero due in tutti i video che faccio
di carattere controverso io tratto di
fatto sempre lo stesso problema è sempre
lo stesso argomento ossia mi scaglio
contro un tipo di narrazione che io ho
definito retorica della superficialità
che cosa che cosa intendo è un tipo di
retorica usata da chi è disonesto
intellettualmente ossia da china non ha
nessun interesse ad andare a fondo nella
questione
a parlare nel merito ad arrivare un
punto di incontro a risolvere un
problema bensì è solo interessato ad
apparire bene a far vedere che ha
ragione a tutti i costi sen
a prescindere da tutto questo questo
tipo di retorica e
è di fatto un tipo di narrazione vuoto
quindi non ha un contenuto dietro c'è
una motivazione personale ognuno ha la
sua motivazione può essere di stampo
politico economico può essere che
debbano sopperire a delle insicurezze
personali però di fatto non c'è
contenuto quindi può sembrare che io
salti dalla politica all'economia con la
leggiadria di un link a wikipedia in
realtà e io mi scaglio sempre su questo
contro questo contenitore vuoto in cui
il contenuto è veramente quasi un
pretesto non esiste e lo faccio
utilizzando la stessa arma che usano
loro ossia un tipo di comunicazione che
si chiama o meno che io ho definito
comunicazione emotiva e già secondo
termine che inventò mi hanno detto che
alte di hicks piace questa cosa quindi
ci ho dato dentro
che cosa intenda è molto semplice sette
minuti quando della perfetta è molto
semplice con il social network si è
creata una condizione che molti chiamano
infonde mia non è un termine del mandato
io stavolta o se la presenza enorme di
informazioni per emergere da queste
informazioni
molti fanno uso di questa comunicazione
emotiva ossia mettono un peso emotivo
sull'informazione per emergere per
rendersi attraenti l'emozione può essere
di qualsiasi tipo può essere
l'allarmismo di solito il
sensazionalismo lo shock di cosa ci sono
un sacco di emozioni diverse
fatto sta che si mette appunto questa
emozione per risaltare io distinto
quattro grandi pilastri da cui
generalmente arriva di informazione nei
social
questo è il classico momento del the
licks in cui dovrei far vedere le mie
slide powerpoint con i grafici e le
citazioni di steve jobs è che finiscano
con una divertentissima vignetta di
snoopy che strappa sempre un sorriso
amaro però hanno portato niente perché
sono pigro perché non so usare power
point però è nulla non è niente di
complicato e sono veramente concetti
super semplici primo pilastro è
l'informazione per eccellenza ossia il
giornalismo il giornalismo fa uso di
comunicazione emotiva dall'alba dei
tempi no con i titoli sensazionalistici
per vendere due copie in più e ora con i
social non è cambiato di nulla cioè usa
ai titoli così dai piccoli
cioè la gente viene attratta a cliccare
sul sul titolo sensazionalistico viene
portata nel sito internet del giornale
vengono mostrati ai pop up pubblicitari
è il giornale prende i soldi quindi i
giornalisti usano comunicazione emotiva
a fine economici per prendere gol sky
come si usa quasi a treviso come dicono
che il secondo pilastro è il pilastro
della politica
anche la politica usa comunicazione
emotiva da quando esiste insieme alla
sua infida retorica e avremo come sempre
l'opposizione che dice tutto uno schifo
larga allarme allarme super catastrofe è
il governo che dice miracolo economico
ma quanto siamo bravi non canto siamo
belli quindi questa comunicazione
emotiva sempre tutto incredibile però a
fini elettorali per prendere due voti
il terzo pilastro non è un vero pilastro
però l'ho inserito per menzione d'onore
per che si è distinto quest'anno
soprattutto con la pandemia è del
pilastro delle teste fuori dal coro cioè
quelli che si vantano di andare
controcorrente contro il pensiero unico
possono essere sia maliziosi cioè
consapevole di star dicendo delle cagate
ma lo fanno per interessi personali per
fare delle truffe oppure il genio che
secondo me molto sottovalutati perché
sono quelli che genuinamente credono in
quello che dicono
vengono in mente quegli scienziati che a
un certo punto non lo so battono la
testa o hanno dei lutti in famiglia
cominciamo a fare delle ricerche
seguendo non propriamente il metodo
scientifico quindi arrivano pensate un
po a dei risultati incredibili si
convincono che questi risultati
incredibili abbiano un certo tipo di
valore e si mettono urlare ai quattro
venti cose del tipo ragazzi non ci
potete credere
penso di aver trovato la cura per il
cancro
esatto lo so è la cosa più assurda che
gli scienziati pensano che io sia pazzo
ma ci potete credere quindi che siano
maliziosi oppure genuini entrambi fanno
uso di questa comunicazione emotiva
perché sempre tutto grandiosa
incredibile o allarmistico per fini di
fatto personale
ultimo pilastro io lo riassumo sotto il
nome di informazione complessa e
quell'informazione esaustiva esauriente
piena di dati e gli approfondimenti
i gestori di queste informazioni sono
convinti che per farlo
sono essere tipo scienziati o anche il
buon giornalismo perché esiste anche
buon giornalismo sono convinti che per
fare una corretta informazione sia
semplicemente necessario e sufficiente
il contenuto quindi non si sprecano
neanche troppo con la comunicazione
secondo me questo è il motivo principale
che ci ha portati alla crisi
dell'informazione soprattutto nell'era
pandemica ossia il fatto che la
comunicazione più efficace che è quella
emotiva
insieme a questa retorica semplice e
superficiale sia stata monopolio di chi
non aveva come primo interessa è quello
di comunicare ma aveva interessi
personali che abbiamo visto possono
essere economici elettorali eccetera
quello che prova a fare io quello che mi
piace fare e dare l'arma della
comunicazione emotiva in mano
all'informazione complessa dato che è
complessa e noiosa e pesante è venuta
spesso sodomizzata a sangue dalla
retorica della superficialità e questo
perché non aveva le stesse armi per
combattere alla pari i miei video sono
come le fake news cioè sono superficiali
perché non posso permettermi di
approfondire troppo l'argomento se ne
perdono di potenza comunicativa sono
semplici semplifico al massimo anche per
poi poter rielaborare l'argomento in
modo artistico e soprattutto hanno il
peso emotivo solo che nel mio caso non
sono non è il sensazionalismo ma il
l'umorismo perché con rendendo facendo
dei video divertenti mi rendo anche
piacevoli da guardare quindi più
facilmente condivisibili quindi non
faccio della divulgazione non mi posso
permettere di farlo perché non è di mia
competenza
faccio una sorta di sensibilizzazione e
una forma di satira che si scaglia non
contro un potente in carne ed ossa non
contro il politico di destra lo
stereotipo no il politico ha corrotto
protek attivo ma contro il potere che
esercita la retorica perché non periodo
come questo in cui tutti potenzialmente
potremmo essere informati su tutto e
democraticamente scegliere ciò che è
meglio per noi questa infida lurida e
schifosa retorica continua a ostacolare
il progresso addirittura volta e ci fa
regredire
quindi tutto questo è il mio mestiere
vorrei concludere con una breve
riflessione che ho fatto proprio
scrivendo questo piccolo monologo per i
tricks una volta quando venivo accusato
di fare propaganda no perché toccavo la
politica io ci ridevo sui dicevo fa a
far signora mia
la propaganda è ben altra cosa io faccio
dai contenuti molto più sofisticati
molto più nobili
in realtà mi sono reso conto che
effettivamente io manipolo le
informazioni io le rielaboro
personalmente e lo faccio per manipolare
a mia volta le persone che non la
pensano in un certo modo quindi per
quanto io possa ritenerne onesto
intellettualmente diverso dagli altri
mi sono reso conto che si io faccio
propaganda però sono dell'altra sponda
grazie per aver partecipato al mio
dell'ex un minuto
[Applauso]